[Música]
buenos días a todos ya todas quiero que
piense empecemos esta presentación
haciendo un pequeño ejercicio quiero que
pensemos en enero del 2020 cuando estaba
empezando el año y en ese esfuerzo
aunque teníamos de inicio del 2020 y
todos los planes que estábamos haciendo
y quiero que haya en casa levanten la
mano y me digan quién es de repente en
enero estaban llenos de planes llenos y
llenas de planes planes de boda planes
de estudiar planes de emprender un nuevo
negocio viajar etcétera y quiero que me
digan ahora quiénes de ustedes pudieron
tener el poder y el control de mantener
esos planes ahora pensando en diciembre
bueno y es que en momentos como los que
estamos viviendo es sumamente difícil
poder
manejar la ansiedad y el estrés ante
tantísima incertidumbre estamos viviendo
un momento donde notamos que no tenemos
control sobre la mayoría de las cosas
que nos pasan desde una separación
amorosa hasta problemas financieros o
qué tal una pandemia global que vino
ponerle pausa absoluta a todos nuestros
planes
y es que crecemos
pensando que estar al control y tener el
control y creando planes que al final
son parámetros ilusorios del éxito es
eso tener éxito y es la manera en la que
nosotros nos valoramos como personas
y bueno para algunas personas estos
planes de éxito pueden ser viajar
estudiar una maestría
emprender un negocio
inclusive tener una banda de metal de
repente para mí eran todos los
anteriores
mi nombre es chilena fach tengo 33 años
y soy la mayor de cuatro por lo tanto
obviamente
soy la ñoña de la familia siempre fui la
nerd a la que sacaba quién es la que
participaba en los actos cívicos como
mejor promedio y participan
absolutamente todo y se metía en todo lo
que lo que podía verdad toda esta
persona que siempre tenía sueños y
siempre tenía planes
y podríamos decir al mismo tiempo que
era una persona adicta y todavía soy un
poco adicta al control a los planes a
las expectativas
hace unos años mi vida iba en un tren a
máxima velocidad de repente todas las
gacetillas que yo me haya puesto como
planes y como cosas que quería alcanzar
en la vida las estaba chequeando
después de haber participado por años y
años para tratar de ganarme una beca de
repente me ganó una beca para estudiar
una maestría en madrid me voy para
madrid
viajo por todo europa que era un sueño y
un plan que siempre había tenido y de
repente inclusive tuve la oportunidad de
conocer la nieve que no la conocía y
tuve la oportunidad de además de poder
vivir en españa y no solamente vivir en
españa sino que también desarrollarme
profesionalmente hay que de nuevo era
otro de mis planes
en el 2017 regreso a costa rica con la
idea de cumplir otro plan que tenía y
era el de emprender un nuevo negocio un
negocio que me llena todavía de un
montón de propósito de un montón de
ganas y que de repente es durante el
primer año me empezó a ir muy bien
empecé a establecerme económicamente y
financieramente
e inclusive esto me permitió que para
alrededor de junio del 2018 después de
10 años de estar ahorrando con un plan
de limbo éste pudiera hacer el primer
pago para comprar mi lote verdad parte
de eso yo quería mi lote mi casa mis
hijos todo este tipo de cosas inclusive
en julio del 2018 me casé me casé con la
persona que yo amaba que yo amaba
teníamos un perrito precioso llamado de
allí teníamos nombres para ponerles a
nuestros hijos o hijas teníamos sueños
de construir un montón de cosas
pero de repente uno puede tener todos
los sueños y todos los planes del mundo
y la vida puede que tenga planes
diferentes para nosotros y nosotros
así fue como en agosto del 2018
justamente un mes después de mi boda me
diagnosticaron con cáncer papilar de
tiroides
o como dicen los doctores y doctoras el
cáncer del que nadie se muere
la tiroides es una glándula muy
pequeñita es una glándula que mide
alrededor de 5 centímetros que está
ubicada por aquí por cualquier cosa que
y una marca que regula resulta que esta
glándula súper bonita tiene esta forma
de mariposa regula todas las funciones
de nuestro cuerpo el metabolismo el peso
la temperatura el sueño y hasta el humor
para mí que siempre fui toda una freak
del control que me quitaran esa glándula
que moderaba y que controlaba todo mi
cuerpo parecía un chiste una broma
injusta del destino
es así como en noviembre del 2018 paso
por el quirófano en este caso cuando uno
tiene cáncer papilar de tiroides lo que
se hace es que se quita absolutamente
toda la tiroides se procede a hacer una
tira directo mía total y más adelante lo
que se hace es que se aplica yodo
radiactivo para poder eliminar todos los
ganglios que probablemente pueden
albergar cáncer paso paso por mí por mi
operación y de repente empiezo a sentir
un montón de cambios en mi entorno pero
principalmente en mi de repente mi
cuerpo estaba fuera de control de un
momento a otro tenía frío luego tenía
calor a veces tenía una depresión
horrible que no podía levantarme de mi
cama me sentía cansada todo el tiempo de
una semana para otro además de repente
subí 9 kilos de repente me di cuenta de
eso que no estaba teniendo control sobre
mi cuerpo
y
lastimosamente pocos meses después de
eso me anuncian una mala noticia y es
que el cáncer del que nadie se muere
resulta ser de los que más rápido se
regeneran
entonces en febrero de 2019 me anuncian
por segunda vez que el cáncer ha
regresado mi cuerpo
en esta etapa de mi vida me doy cuenta
que las personas ante situaciones
difíciles toman una modalidad de luchar
o huir
en mi caso yo no tuve mucha opción tenía
mucho por qué luchar mi trabajo mi
emprendimiento mi clientela mi familia
mi matrimonio
pero había otras personas que de repente
salieron de mi vida las primeras
personas que salieron de mi vida fueron
muchos de mis clientes que de repente
para ellos y para ellos mi situación o
mi cáncer era un inconveniente
y dos semanas antes de mi segunda
operación la persona a quien más yo creo
quería llamaba en ese momento y que me
había estado acompañando con quien tenía
cinco años de relación y siete meses de
matrimonio
decidió huir
mi ex esposo decidió ir y huye con las
siguientes palabras y es la frase una de
las frases más dolorosas que me han
dicho a mí en la vida y es literalmente
yo no quiero apartamento
yo no quiero perritos
yo no quiero hijos yo no quiero lo que
yo no quiero casa yo no quiero nada
definitivamente y más claro que eso no
podía estar
de un pronto otro mis planes ya no eran
sus planes y ahora que yo logro
retrospectiva entiendo realmente nunca
lo fueron
quebrada con una depresión como nunca
había tenido hecha por dentro y
por fuera firme dos días antes de mi
operación mi divorcio y ese mismo día
inclusive firmé los papeles de lote con
lágrimas en los ojos no con alegría
estaba pasando por una depresión
horrible y estaba me sentía muy sola
de repente no tenía fuerza para seguir
luchando como lo estaba haciendo
y recuerdo que mis amigos y amigas me
ayudaron a pasarme ya no tenía ya había
perdido clientes ya no tenía la
tranquilidad financiera que tuve en su
momento ya no podía pagarme apartamento
y con costos podía pagar mi lote agarré
mis maletas y me fui para la casa mi
madre que siempre ha tenido los brazos
abiertos para mí y que siempre me trató
y me ha tratado como una gran amiga y
que de repente se iba a convertir en mi
compañera número uno de lucha porque muy
poco tiempo después
lastimosamente me avisarían que el
cáncer del que nadie se muere había
vuelto por una tercera vez
yo para este momento ya estaba harta
estaba harta de todo y yo decía bueno ok
la tercera la vencida nada más tengo que
esperar pronto me van a hacer mi tercera
operación y voy a poder disfrutar por
fin de el tratamiento de los reactivos
no sé si disfrutarse a la palabra pero
voy a pasar por yo reactivo y muy pronto
voy a estar fuera de esto pase por mi
tercera operación en noviembre del 2019
y a partir de esto no había ni siquiera
ha terminado operarme cuando de repente
estaba armando otros planes más planes
más planes más planes está planeando
irme a europa a visitar a mi hermana que
estaba que estaba trabajando ya quería
ir a celebrar mi remisión y ni siquiera
había entrado una remisión que estaba
haciendo planes de nuevo y los planes
como sabemos se caen
pero bueno un día de repente recibí la
muy esperada llamada de la junta médica
les explico un poco cómo funciona esto
de la junta médica y qué es la junta
médica
la junta médica se reúne normalmente
cuando a darle noticias a un paciente
sobre su estado especialmente en temas
de cáncer oncología diferentes verdad
diferentes este enfermedades o
diferentes padecimientos
la junta médica normalmente es un cuarto
pequeño donde hay un montón de doctores
y doctoras rodeándote vos está sentado
en una sillita con sentada en una
sillita y nada más te estás bien te
están viendo y es un estado de
vulnerabilidad súper fuerte mucho miedo
yo me recuerdo inclusive que es a esa
cita a la junta médica fui sola porque
yo estaba esperando las mejores noticias
yo estaba esperando que ya me dijeran
que voy a poner yodo reactivo y que ya
esto se iba a acabar por lo menos por un
tiempo
pues dije la junta médica me dijeron
elena tenemos buenas y malas noticias
para usted las buenas noticias es que lo
que lo que tenía lo que le sacamos salió
negativo a lo que yo respondí no puedo
creer en un ser yo no tengo cáncer y los
doctores y doctoras me respondieron no
todavía tiene cáncer lo que pasa es que
le sacamos algo que no era su cáncer y
hay que volver a operar por una cuarta
vez
en este momento yo ya había perdido
prácticamente las ganas de todo había
perdido
clientes había perdido mi estabilidad
financiera había perdido un apartamento
había acababa de perder mi matrimonio y
los doctores lo que me decían era lo
bueno es que no se va a morir de esto
después de esto llegamos a febrero 2020
y que pasa llega alcohol y 19 y qué
significaba esto que se iban a celebrar
las fronteras médicas inevitablemente
cuando esto pasó para mí fue una
incertidumbre super grande porque como
ya vemos mi cáncer verdad o mis tumores
crecían de una manera muy acelerada
todavía no tenía yodo radiactivo y tenía
mucho miedo porque además en todas las
operaciones me decían muchacha es en
esta operación usted va a perder la voz
tenía tanto miedo de lo que estaba
pasando que de repente yo sentía como
que me pegaban olas todo el tiempo y en
todo este camino era como que me pegaba
una ola yo me caía me volvió a levantar
me pegaba otra ola me caía me volvía a
levantar y me canse
y decidí tomar una alternativa diferente
decidí para este momento soltar y dejar
ir
y es que soltar es muy diferente perder
y eso es algo que aprendí
soltar es un acto completamente
voluntario a diferencia de perder que
requiere un esfuerzo grandísimo requiere
ser entrenado es una capacidad que
requiere ser entrenada como un músculo
todo el tiempo en todas las ocasiones
con todas las personas y ante cualquier
situación por lo tanto también soltar
significaba que yo me convertía en la
protagonista de mi propia historia en
lugar de la víctima y soltar también
además de que trae muchos beneficios
soltar es súper doloroso porque de
repente hacemos nos enlazamos hacemos
lazos con personas con cosas con ideas
con planes que cuando se caen nos
rompemos y no sabemos cómo reaccionar
ante esto
pasa que de repente cuando yo empiezo a
soltar empiezan a pasar cosas
maravillosas en mi vida en medio de una
pandemia con los hospitales saturados
porque hoy 19 me llaman un día del
hospital y me dicen elena venga ya
tenemos un espacio tenemos una camilla
la podemos operar en este momento y de
repente si fue en marzo recibí mi cuarta
operación de cáncer de tiroides
y empecé a sanar súper bien y la
operación fue bastante exitosa ahora
sólo quedaba el yodo radiactivo y
resulta que muy poco tiempo después me
llaman del hospital de igual manera y me
dicen elena véngase ya que podemos darle
yo predictivo y aunque yo reactivo es
una experiencia horrible que no le deseo
nada y ya yo por fin estaba dándole
cierre a una etapa que me que me había
costado todo en donde había perdido
tanto
y al mismo tiempo me ayudó a soltar
muchísimo y cuando uno suelta eso es
algo que es muy interesante cuando uno
suelta
la vida hay un dicho que dice que la
vida no le quita uno no le quita lo que
no está para uno y le trae lo que sí
cuando uno suelta empieza a abrirse
camino para que otras cosas entren en
nuestras vidas
de repente yo estaba en mi cama estuve
una semana con yodo radiactivo en
recuperación en un momento verdad que
pasa vomitando como al estar lejos de
todas las personas que yo quería y
justamente en ese momento empecé a
escribir este télex y yo pensé me dio
mucho tiempo a reflexionar y pensé
realmente que era todo esto que es lo
que me estaba enseñando esto para que me
estaba pasando esto y me di cuenta que
al final del día el control era mi
cáncer
los planes la ansiedad todas estas cosas
exigencias que yo me ponía a mí misma
eran mi cáncer y que por más planes que
yo hiciera no importa la cantidad de
planes que yo hiciera yo me estaba
haciendo daño a mí misma porque estaba
siendo víctima de mis propias
expectativas
hoy finalmente celebro y estoy feliz
porque estoy en una etapa de remisión
una etapa de remisión que me ha enseñado
muchísimas cosas me ha enseñado
a sanar y a curar mis cicatrices con
paciencia si en mí misma de asia a los
demás me ha enseñado empatía me ha
enseñado
amor me han se me ha mostrado que estoy
llena de amor de personas que me quieren
de mi familia de mis amigos de mis
amigas de las personas con las que
trabajo los y las clientes que tengo en
este momento
mi novio que me apoyó muchísimo durante
todo este proceso e inclusive un nuevo
amigo
de 11 años que me hace justo de amor
cuando llegó a la casa
tal vez
no tengo en este momento mi lote
no tengo en este momento mis propios
hijos y algunos de estos planes que yo
tenía para mi vida tal vez no se dieron
de acuerdo a este plan pero mil miles de
otras cosas mejores están pasando en
este momento en mi vida yo me siento tan
agradecida y tan feliz y el logrado
aceptar y amar esta nueva versión de mí
una versión un poco más lenta una
versión un poco
menos ambiciosa pero muchísimo más en
paz
muchísimo más
desapegada y menos en control una
versión que ahora en lugar de esperar a
que le peguen las olas y levantarse y
pega y que le pegue las olas y
levantarse decide voluntariamente soltar
y sumergirse entre las olas
y dejar que la vida fluya
muchas gracias
[Música]